dans le domaine médical une équipe de
chirurgie à allemand vient de réaliser
une prouesse technologique qui est aussi
une première mondiale
ces médecins est implanté sur un patient
à coeur artificiel qui fonctionne sans
câble ni fils explications avec jean
daniel flaysakier c'est le dernier né
des coeurs artificiels tout en titane 1
kg 6 il remplace le ventricule gauche
chez un patient dans le coeur ne
fonctionne plus il permet d'attendre
plusieurs mois que la greffe et mais il
a surtout un gros avantage sa batterie
est implanté sous la peau
plus besoin de câbles qui dépasse et
donc moins de risques d'infection le
chargeur se porte à la ceinture et on
peut l'enlever deux fois par jour 20
minutes à chaque fois de quoi prendre
une douche par exemple la qualité de vie
est grandement améliorée ce dispositif
peut à mon avis remplacer un jour la
transplantation pour le coeur donc tout
va bien en revanche pour la cicatrice il
y a sans doute quelques petits progrès à
faire